oh
watch a gray disc speed in from the left
and then an explosion right above the
Kremlin one of two drone attacks on
Tuesday night the Kremlin says
here a different view of an image for
the history books
Moscow blames Kiev saying this was an
assassination attempt on President Putin
Kiev says it wasn't them
we don't attack
Putin or Moscow
how we fight on on our territory we are
defending our Villages and cities
President Putin was elsewhere and
unscathed but days before Russia's
annual military parade this suggests
embarrassing security weaknesses
this will be the second Victory Day
parade that Vladimir Putin has held
since he sent troops into Ukraine and 15
months in there is not much in the way
of Victory to chauffeur it especially
not since Russia's Retreat from kerson
last November just a degree of nervous
apprehension about what Ukraine's long
promised counter-offensive might hold in
store
Russians we spoke to were reluctant to
believe that these drone strikes had
even happened
it couldn't have happened we can't have
that happening here
[Laughter]
I haven't heard this information if
there was such an attempt it doesn't
sound good I hope there'll be a response
there have been a Spate of strikes in
russian-occupied Crimea and Russia
itself in recent weeks and months drone
strikes on oil Depots and airfields
freight trains derailed by suspected
saboteurs and of course the attack on
the Kirch Bridge linking Russia with
Crimea last October
the symbolism of flames above the
Kremlin is on a similar scale
whoever's responsible it's not
militarily very significant there was a
very small charge it's not really blown
up anything it's not really done any
damage but symbolically it's incredibly
important it's the heart of Russian
power it's the Kremlin it's the Fortress
this is a very powerful slap in the face
for uh President Putin it'll be
interesting to see what he does as a
result Fortress Russia on the defensive
and Gathering itself for a response
Sky News Moscow